hello everyone welcome back to PGA chain
design today we're gonna work on this
engagement ring have this kind of wavy
design on the side with the besetting
are you ready let's get started we are
going to start it with the center stone
is oval it's around six by eight and I
have a video in the description below if
you want to know how to do the prong set
in 3d model but we're gonna starting
with this setting in the middle for our
reference so I'm just going to hide it
and then we are going to set it a ring
size the diameter for the ring is about
16 millimeter at first we need to edit
this circle there's not much of an edit
point right here and then they were also
creating this kink right there so what
we want to do is we need to rebuild this
curve let's rebuild it into the point
count for 8 degree for 3 and this is
what we get once we rebuild it we are
going to pick up this point at this
point they are going to move it to the
right let's say 3 millimeter and then
the one right in the middle there I'm
going to move it back point 3
millimeters so I get something like this
ok let's go ahead to creating the
profile I'm going to creating the
profile right here snapping into the
cause 1 and the high it's about 1.5
millimeters so I'm going to have 1 point
7 millimeter and wanna give it a little
bit round corner there okay so this is
what we have let's move it back to the
center by align to horizontal Center and
we want to also want to make a copy to
the other side alright so now we have
everything ready we need to create two
more profile there right one in the
middle the other one at that 45 degree
so let's go ahead to use the rotate tool
that's snapping over here and type a 45
and also another
one type in 90 so we will have two
additional cross section there with this
one let's go ahead to move it close to
where that rayo is going to be the same
one in the middle I'm going to move it
to close to where the rail is going to
be let me hide this one so it's easier
for you to see the reason we want to
have that 45 there is because one side
is going to be higher than the other
side so I'm going to do is using the 1d
scale I'm going to scale this up just a
little bit doesn't have to be too tall
we just need to have a little bit more
definition there okay so let's go ahead
to use the sweep one rail this is our
rail and the rest of this is a cross
section make sure everybody's aligned I
usually like them to align in the inside
of the ring shank so that way I can
avoid you have a seam on my design
and make sure they are facing the same
direction also close to sweep so now we
have something look like this this side
look a little bit fatter we want to do a
test let's go ahead to rotate that piece
and make sure that copy equal yes so
then you will get this one as you can
see let's get take a look on the render
view like one side is higher than the
other side in a meeting right in the
middle over there so I'm not happy with
the button look like a but looking
things up up we can fix that later on
let's turn on the stone and see how's
everything work all right so now
everything is working fine we just need
to put the stone there and redo the
button so I'm going to do is to draw a
straight line and using the straight
line to trim the surface right there
okay so now I have something like this
I'm going to pick up my curve on that
profile and then we want to make a copy
by using the rotate copy equal yes let's
make one to the bottom so now we have
something like this we're going to use
the
surface tool sweep one we're gonna go
from rail cross-section cross-section
and the the last cross-section and make
sure they are aligned to the middle and
then we can create its let's take
a look on the render view so it coming
into one shank instead of two okay so
now let's go ahead to do the stone to do
the stone we need to know where the
stone is going to be so I'm going to use
duplicate ages and we're gonna duplicate
this ages right there let's move it to
the other layer so it's easier for us to
work on it so this is the curve that we
have we don't need the whole section
there I'm going to split that curve to
the point where I think the stone should
stop and then so we can did it the other
half okay so this is the curve that we
have I need to know how long is that so
we're gonna use the command called
length it's thirteen point one two eight
so on the top view I'm gonna come over
here to draw a line thirteen point one
two eight so this means if this curve is
to stretch it like flat the flat surface
this is how long it's going to be so I
bring the stone that I made before if
you want to know how to make this stone
I will including the video in the
description so let's take a look on the
top view I want to make the two stone
next to each other and then I'm going to
draw a straight line at the front view
approximately something like this in the
middle okay so this is going to indicate
where the prong is going to be we are
going to pipe this one make sure your
prong is big enough to cover both of the
stone I will say you will cover about 20
percent so now we have something like
this let's just go ahead to mirror to
the other side so then we'll have the
prong on posa I'm going to delete this
one
let's go ahead to use the linear array
and we are going to go about 10 because
I don't know how many do I need it and
we're gonna go something like this you
want to make sure that it's equal size
on the prong both side of the prong and
then you got something like this and
peroneal have more than what I need so
I'm going to delay one of them here okay
I also need the prong on the other side
so I'm just gonna move it over here and
have something like this okay so this is
the arrangement that I have and we are
going to have this one flow back to this
one so I'm going to pick up everybody
beside that curve and we are going to
use the command under the transform you
have flow a long curve and the base
curve will be the curve over here the
target curve will be the curve over here
alright so then this is what we have
let's turn on a ring to see if that fit
right so you fill it nicely once we have
done that you can still adjust it if you
need it and then we can come over here
just pick up everybody again and let's
go ahead to rotate our stone and make
sure copy equal yes Center to the zero
and let's move it to the other side so
double check the stone flow nicely this
H of a stone is now hanging out the
prong is touching both sides of the
stone all we need to do now is to trim
the extra once everything is trimmed so
and also trim the one in the center if
you like to know more about stone
setting I have a stone setting course
online I will put the description below
check it out and let me know if you have
any question thank you for watching I'll
see you next
[Music]